would he be willing to look past his  girl getting naked on camera for other  men should he should he do that why  should he do that  if it's the right girl  I don't like this narrative there's one  right girl for you you but I also you  don't like the narrative that there's no  value in women who do only fans and they  lose  it's needed in society actually but but  I'm a relationship like I feel like  that's for you okay what value would you  bring to a guy by like showing your  boobs why do you act like the only value  is what they do online it's not like  you're completely dismissing like who  somebody is as a person same things  Emily said I'll tell you to cook I clean  I just suck good dick  listen I take accountability like  there's a lot of things you can value  and I make money by showing you guys you  guys said yourself on my show that it  causes you guys trauma so why would I  tell him to pick a girl that has more  trauma